well welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is Caleb Denby and I'm
your driver on this journey so what I
wanted to talk about today was some of
the games that we actually just had at
the tournament going on here at the
Chess Club the champions showdown so
this is the of course the the five
matches going on between the five best
American players and five top players
from around the world and there was a
kind of a common theme that started
early on today which was a lot of games
were decided not in the opening not in
the middle game but in the end game so
that's gonna be the topic of the lecture
tonight is we're gonna look at some of
these end games and how one player
managed to come out on on top at the end
of them so to start off here we've got a
game between Accardo Nakamura and his
opponent and in this match Yan Duda so
yeah let's let's see how this game went
I'm just gonna go quickly through it
till we get to the point where we're in
the end game because that's you know of
course the main topic so we got a 45 out
of three of four Knights the first set
of pieces were traded moving along got a
couple more trades black regains his
pawn yet another piece comes off and now
we see at this point here so I think
this is when a you know that the end
game really officially starts we see the
last minor piece come off and also the
Queen's so I'm going to call this the
starting point of the endgame so right
off the bat what are your first
impressions what do you look at when you
first see this position for see the son
game yeah yeah that's exactly right one
thing to do is to find out who has the
better pawn structure one way of doing
that is counting the pawn islands of
course Black has four separate pawn
islands you know groups of pawns that
aren't connected to each other and he
also has these double isolated pawns as
one of you know the
Islands so black definitely has some
weaknesses what else are you looking at
when you when you first see this
position besides the pawn structure
sure you definitely look at the Kings
and one the thing that you mentioned was
King activity the other thing is King
safety and a lot of end games especially
when there's more than one major piece
on the board so if you want to call
blacks King more active you know that's
that's something you can do it can
definitely help support these three
pawns White's King is also a not so
active but uh I mean it's the Kings
aren't gonna serve you know too much of
a useful purpose here the important
thing is that you know they stay safe
with that in mind who has the the safer
King rather than the more active King
since there are two rooks left on the
board
yeah maybe white they're both pretty
safe for the moment but you can
definitely see that you know this this
King has a lot more open space around it
due to this messed up pawn structure so
white has a slight advantage in maybe
King's safety and as well as pawn
structure is there anything you know
that black kind of has going for him
what's the last big thing to look at in
this endgame yes so black has controlled
the e-file so the last thing in general
that you want to look at is the piece
activity so who has the more active
pieces so looking at it you know both
players actually do have some active
pieces though right you know white can
invade on this B file and is attacking
this this week C pawn meanwhile black is
looking to invade on this efile and is
attacking the weak deep on so you know
players I think both have some active
pieces right now what it's going to come
down to is who can you know use them
more effectively to target the
opponent's weaknesses and in the end
we've already decided Black has more
weaknesses so white should definitely
have the edge in this endgame that's
kind of the three things that I would
look at when I'm just evaluating a
position like this
so the pawn structure the Kings as well
as the piece activity and if you want to
list those in order of importance I'd
say piece activity is almost always the
most important a lot of times having
active pieces is even more important
than having more material like you know
having active pieces can definitely be
compensation for a pawn even in
when there's not so much left on the
board so let's see how a white chose to
continue here of course it'd be a
mistake to try to take this pawn right
away because of the weak back rank so
white first plays h3 giving his king of
flight square now of course white is
threatening to take this pawn so black
starts with Rick to d7 and now white
simply plays kind of a waiting move kind
of a useful move rook to c2 so of course
what was the purpose of this move yeah
it stops the the black rook from
invading right you know white would love
to try to you know invade right away it
first of all it gives up this pawn and
then it also ends up giving up the
second-ranked eventually you know maybe
why it would take but you know you know
black black could start to invade so
Nakamura simply plays you know good
chess he decides okay I'm not I'm not
gonna let you in at all and plays Rick
see to now we see York to e5
so already you can really tell that the
players are focusing on the activity of
their pieces white wanted to limit
blacks activity black is still trying to
find good squares for his rook and you
know targets to attack targets in this
d3 pawn and this a to pawn we see King
to g1 white is improving his King
riki to d5 black decides to focus on
this target rook c2 c3 simply defending
King g7 King f2 just both players
improving their Kings we see pulling to
c5 which this move is you know it's got
some benefits and it's also got some
downsides so what is one benefit of pawn
to c5
yeah it increases the activity you could
say of this rook right it has more
squares to go to and it's also stopping
this rook from coming in now how about
some of the downsides what do you think
yeah it's it's actually maybe becoming
more weak as it becomes closer to you
know white side of the board closer to
this pawn and then the last thing you
might want to mention is you know this
trick no longer has the option of
swinging over here although I'm not sure
it was ever such a huge deal so you know
black has more than one weakness in the
position so White's finally trying to
you know just limit blacks options by
focusing his rooks on these two weak
pawns on the Queen side so we see York
to a3 aiming at the a7 pawn black plays
f5 white plays rook to a4 so now without
looking at this notation here would you
take on d3 do you think this is a good
idea or a bad idea and then let me get
your thoughts on why obviously the line
might go something like you know Rick
takes d3 and then white gets the c5 pawn
in exchange he could also take back on
d3 and take a 7 but I think you'd rather
have c5 so we'll say rook takes d3 Rick
takes c5 and then you know white might
be aiming at this F pawn and what do you
think of that position compared to this
position White's winning ok so you would
go for it so as black would you go for
this Leonard would you think okay
White's getting too active this is not
something I want to do
so what would you play instead simply
something like you know king f6 maybe
mm-hmm so uh okay so your answer is you
know you wouldn't take it because white
gets too active that's what you're
afraid of
so in the game do to actually did
capture this pawn and there are a few
reasons for it the simplest one and the
main one is well you know white is
getting slightly more active black is
also getting things in exchange so what
is black getting in exchange for
allowing this white rook to you know
kind of be freed and to take black C
pawn so yeah
Black's rooks are also getting active
right why it's not the only one
gaining inactivity here whites blacks
going to invade the second rank and then
there's another big achievement that
black has made by taking this d3 pawn
and exchange for c5 and it's kind of a
self-evident but the point is black is
defending this endgame right we all
agreed black is slightly worse and when
you're slightly worse especially in your
Ken games there's always the adage you
know trade pawns not pieces so black is
simply taking more pawns off the board
with every set of pawns that comes off
black is closer to achieving that draw
so because of those reasons we do see
York to d3 rook to c5 and then maybe you
know Duda just calculated further than
everybody here but due to decided you
know he probably isn't actually also
losing this pawn in the game he went
ahead with rook to d2 King to g3 hmm and
now he played a the interesting move f4
check so again this is following that
same principle he wants to trade off
more pawns get closer to that draw an
endgame so what would happen if King
takes obviously
yeah he loses the Jeep on and then the
more natural rook takes yeah he loses
they upon so this was you know blacks
kind of idea so if you didn't see this
line it is harder to go for this but
he's simply following the classic
principles he wants to trade off pawns
he wants to increase his activity he
wants to get closer to that force draw
in the game we saw actually Rick takes
and black takes on a two and this is
something I wanted to talk about as well
because this is also an interesting
decision why do you think white gave up
this a pawn instead of this Jeep on yeah
one thing is that uh you know his pawns
are simply stronger when they're in one
group the other thing is when you want
to win in an endgame you need some kind
of an imbalance right and so having this
pawn line up with this pawn you know all
the pawns line up with each other you
have no past pawns you have no chance of
making a passed pawn you're never going
to win this game but when you take like
this suddenly you created an imbalance
right
you've given black this free passed pawn
like had to do nothing to achieve this
you just gave it to him
but you've also given yourself the
opportunity to push these pawns down the
board and makes them threats on the
other side so it's imbalances like these
that lead to you know players kind of
slipping and kind of allowing the other
player to slip through so this is what
happened in the game
white continued with Dirk to g4 check
came to f8 so I'd you know line lining
up his York here why it played rook c8
check King e7 rook over to h8 and what
do you think black should play here
there's a couple different paths you can
take that both makes sense and in trying
to defend this position yeah a five a
five is a great idea so what's the point
in playing a five here
yeah that's right the thinking is you
know okay well why it is busy trying to
take my poems over here I'll simply get
this pawn to a two it won't matter what
he has on the queenside because I'll
just simply be queening so that's one
idea
for trying to you know get your own
chances or trying to draw is to make
threats with your past pawn what's the
other thing black can try though in this
position yeah you can also just take
control the second rank here and white
would have to defend this pawn somehow
maybe with King to h2 and what would you
play here
well yeah you can you can play a five
but yeah that's a great idea so if you
wanted to play a five if you're I would
just say you should have played a five
in the first place because this trick
might be better on d7 then but yeah this
idea of bringing your hook to the third
to attack this pawn is actually correct
I might use this truck instead though
just because of the way the pieces line
up and so with this pawn attacks there's
only a few ways y can defend it coming
back to the first to unpin doesn't work
because we can simply give this check
and repeat so white might have to play
something like pawn to f4 and you know
what the advance of this pawn white is
actually creating a few more weaknesses
and now let's see I'm not sure the most
accurate way to continue here I didn't
have a you know the entire endgame
memorized but Black has created some
more weaknesses he's activated his rooks
and so this is kind of another way black
can go about it is trying to you know
now maybe attack this F pawn somehow I'm
not sure maybe rook to f2 maybe work to
d4 and when you take here maybe I'll
play something like rook to a4 excuse me
so yeah just kind of this active defense
where black is posing some some problems
for for white because his pieces are
kind of awkwardly placed while he's
taking this pawn on age 7 this is the
type of thing stockfish goes for I think
a5 is much more natural and as such this
is what Duda actually went for in the
game but this is kind of where his
problems started to begin is you know
this a pawn wasn't quite fast enough to
make up for White's pawns in the Kings
side so we do see York age 7 and again
Duda can go for this sort of
weird-looking Rick to d2 what the idea
of putting pressure on this pawn instead
we see rook to a7 putting the rook
behind the passed pawn which is another
principle that everybody learns about
onions but it's not actually correct
here even with this plan of pushing the
pawn forward I think it makes more sense
just to
in you with a four rather than play okay
seven just cuz it's it's simply faster
it's a faster way of getting this this
done but we do sir Rick to a seven and
now Hikari who simply continues with
Rick to f4 you know he's taking the H
bond he's taking the F pawn now so black
of course doesn't want to allow this so
he plays King back to f8 and now we
simply CH 4 so white has managed to you
know scrounge up a pawn advantage and
now he's going to just push his pawns
down the board we see a for h5 King G
eights or okay h6 the only reasonable
move a three
both players just pushing their pawn
forward work to g4 check with the idea
of preventing the King from forcing this
wreck to awkward squares King f8 okay
Jay King g7 hh6
rook a 1 h7 rook h1 wreckage for takes
takes okay for g4 and already this is
hopelessly lost because after a - of
course what's the final winning blow yet
sacrificing the work on e8 so you can
queen with check and then stop this pawn
and black resigned shortly after
actually he resigned here because
there's no way to stop white from
forking the king and rook so what do you
think actually ended up going wrong
there for black because it looked like
he played very naturally even up till
the ends even here he has some sort of
chances to try to save this game
any ideas about what went wrong uh yeah
so he attacked the rook but yeah I think
you're right here actually King to g7
was kind of the the one last try it that
he could make forcing the struck kind of
to an awkward square maybe to f6 and
it'd be slightly harder for for white to
try to push through maybe now something
like a three I'm not completely certain
and if you try to push eight six age six
through will see a king aged seven and
you might end up in this son game which
is gonna be a lot harder to win with
this pawn uh you know so far up the
board so that was maybe dude as last
chance but I think even that endgame the
line I showed might not be totally
accurate but even after King g7 white
still has very good chances to win just
simply because of his his pwnage so yeah
does everybody understand how Nakamura
kind of won the second game cuz it
didn't come out of nowhere any questions
about how it sort of happens because a
lot of times in these rare kind games
you can just be going along like okay
all these moves make sense everything
looks natural but then all of a sudden
one players winning right and I just
wanted to make it clear that Nakamura's
edge kind of at first came through black
allowing White's rooks in although this
decision was fine black then had to
continue to play actively by bringing a
this rook to the second rank right he
kind of you know let rooks in and then
gave up on you know his his active game
plan with the rooks and decided okay I'm
just gonna push this pawn and it turned
out it simply wasn't fast enough
so he should have gone for this this
work to d2 idea in my opinion so yeah
that that's the first trick endgame
which is kind of the most mysterious one
because we went into it here even
material the only advantage is you know
these pawns are slightly weak and then a
Nakamura did end up you know managing to
win it and what it always comes down to
is reactivity white got his works in he
won a pawn and then he pushed on to
victory
so yeah the next game is this one
between Wesley so and David navara
instead of flipping through the game
really quickly I'm just gonna jump to
the position so we see uh let's see I
guess we can start it here so we see
rook takes rook pawn takes rook and York
do one so we're not quite to just a
plain rook versus reckon game yet
there's still bishops on the board but
what do you think about this one any
ideas on who might be better here who
might be worse here if it's drawn or if
it's winning or if you know there any
winning chances all these questions yeah
it looks pretty even right but you like
white and why is that yeah you know
white has these three pawns altogether
and again simply the the pawn structure
this this pawn is weak and you know as a
result of this pawn being weak white is
going to have active pieces because he
has a target to focus on so already
white has a slight edge I would say it's
probably not enough to to win the game
yet obviously it's not like he's he's up
any material yet but let's you know see
how the game continued the game went d8
defending the pawn rook to d3 and now a
black right away goes for this move pawn
to d4 and so again we see these top
grandmasters always you know remembering
these principles I'm defending the
position I want to trade off my
weaknesses on a trade off pawns get
closer to that draw and they do this in
like every game every endgame they
always follow these principles so of
course white wants to keep pawns on the
board which is why we see this move pawn
to c4 direct c8b three defending Bishop
c5 H takes G H H takes G and so I just
said they always follow these principles
but why did white allow this pawn
capture to actually happen why not play
something like h5
yeah it's keeping pawns on the board but
it's keeping a weakness for white on the
board I mean one of this age six pawn
isn't so easily attacked right so it's
basically just giving white another
weakness
so I decided instead okay I'll just take
it off the board and now we see Bishop
to e5 here attacking blacks weakness
again and black plays this interesting
move rook to c6 rather than defending
the pawn so fortunately for black this
is defending the pawn kind of indirectly
so how is that yeah exactly you can't
take with the bishop because of this
simple tactic depending the bishop to
the rook so instead we see York to d2
now of course if luck does nothing white
can take and play Bishop c3 and then uh
okay this pawn is hanging in the end but
this pawn is also hanging in the end so
white would be up upon so instead what
do you think black should do here
instead of something some passing move
yeah you could push the deep on to open
up this Bishop on this F pawn here
that's actually an interesting idea but
the problem is maybe uh yeah Y could
simply defend the pawn first yeah yeah
I'm sorry f3 you're you're right
probably isn't the best move but I think
this Bishop III might be doing the trick
yeah it's very well spotted but the with
Rick h6 yeah and then uh simply on the
next turn white and I capture this pawn
but yeah d3 is interesting
maybe d3 in tandem with this other idea
could also work a bit better
yeah that's the right idea trying to
focus on ways to activate your pieces
yeah Rick's at age six to h4 that's an
interesting way to try to defend the
pawn this is actually not an idea I've
looked at too in-depth maybe the problem
is simply g3 here right and then your
rook ends up well I guess you go to e4
hmm let's see yeah this is an
interesting idea I keep being tempted to
play f3 but it's you're still
checkmating me perhaps King f1 here and
I'll simply threaten to play f3 and g3
and I'll you know it increased my king's
activity the length of you can keep
going though any other ideas for black
here maybe like rookie for rookie for
makes the most sense to me something
like Bishop g3 and then uh my idea is
still to play this f3 and Bishop Bishop
f2 did you know keep increasing pressure
on this pawn but ok so the idea I was
looking for was simply something like
rook to a6 so increasing their works the
activity this way by finding a target in
White's camp this is a you know a pretty
common way to increase activity cuz
activity can be kind of a general term
that really has no meaning like okay a
piece can be active but not useful and
so we're looking for active pieces that
serve a useful purpose so this rip
qualifies because it's attacking a
weakness so now of course if white were
to take we would simply you know trade
pawns so maybe why it tries to defend
this somehow with something like a 4
then maybe black can simply go to b6 and
there's a new weakness for white to deal
with so this would be an interesting way
for black to try to
you know keep keep his pawns together
yeah yes so a four probably isn't the
best move maybe it's fine but the point
was White's not going to be able to take
this pawn until he's dealt with this a
pawn in a more permanent fashion but say
yeah I think you're right something like
King here might just make more sense but
the problem is you know of course black
can also get his King in the game so uh
you know he's going to be holding on to
this pawn for a lot longer this way but
yeah I like this Rick aged six idea I
like these d3 ideas as well all of them
I think are better than what black
played in the game which is simply rook
to e6 which didn't make a whole lot of
sense to me
I still haven't fully unpacked it I
guess he's trying to you know just get
his rook into the first rank or the
second rank but yeah it seems like a
much worse way to keep the defense right
so we do see white take this pawn and
now the bishops do you come off and we
have this Rick end game once again black
comes into the second forking these two
pawns but unfortunately for him after
Rick d7 or kf2 we see this move a four
which is quite strong so right now the
material is even but why it's going to
take up take another pawn basically of
course it'd be mistake to take here
because again it's trading more pawns
getting closer to a draw so okay so yeah
this a4 move is actually quite strong
because again it keeps pieces on the
board gives White's more chances to win
the game of course black just keeps
playing more natural moose he plays b6
any idea why he'd rather give the a pawn
than the B phone
well yeah the b-pawn is easier to defend
in the a pond the b-pawn also is
stopping both of whites passers for the
moment or potential passers I mean while
the a pond you know obviously has no
influence over the sea pawn
the other thing is you'd like to keep
this B file closed so we can attack this
b3 pond because of all this you know b6
is played we see York takes a seven rook
to be two rook p7 takes and now I have a
question for you so first of all what
are some ideas for white here how does
he keep the game going and second of all
you know there's a very distinct choice
once you see the idea so yeah of course
he'd like to push the C pawn or the a
pawn the question is which one and why
okay I'm a bit confused by your
reasoning what do you think's gonna
happen after you push yeah what does
black do there
so let's talk in specifics so let's say
you push a 5 what is blacks move rook a
3 but then simply the a pawn takes the
be pawn right and then your you've
connected passers and the game would be
over so black has to has to do better
than that he just asked you
he's Dave Navarro he's got to do better
so if he pushes then a it'd still be
captured right
so in an ideal world he'd like to unpin
so he's threatening to take the pawn
with his pawn right and he'd also like
to create another threat so how can he
unfinished pawn and make a threat on
another pawn or another piece yeah
that's exactly right
so after something like a five we'll see
York to c3 and so you know black will be
getting this pawn yeah exactly
and after c5 we'd see something similar
right he would have to play Rick to a3
and he'd be taking this pawn so now that
we know what's basically going to happen
we know our opponents only try would we
rather have him be taking our a pond or
have him be taking our C pond why you
think the C pawn is more valuable or
less valuable less valuable yeah that's
exactly right it all comes down to these
endgame principles you know these Dirk
end games they can seem mysterious at
times but when the key moments come the
Grand Master's almost always are
following these these principles which
is why they're taught which is why you
should follow them in your games too so
of course the outside past pond is
always going to be more valuable because
this king is going to have a very hard
time getting the a file and it's going
to have a far easier time getting to the
C file to stop this pawn so after
something like c5 maybe we see like rook
to a3 c6 black would have to take the
time to insert this this trick to this
King to g7 move so we're not losing a
pawn but this question slow remains
would you rather have a pawn get to c7
or pawn get to a7 and of course by the
same reasoning you would rather have the
pawn on a7 say it my bet on that one but
yeah we do see I a five or exceed three
sees a six King g7 and a seven of course
getting the pawn as far up the board as
possible so yeah
and now let's see rook to a3 the only
move and find the best move for white
here let's figure it out
white smooth white to move see how what
can you try to do oh yes so we can you
know bring the king over there's
something you should do before this
though and so it's like a quick story I
was sitting at the front desk of the
Chess Club Wesley so finished his last
round for the day it come down you know
he was chatting with everybody it's a
very personable guy and he looked at my
computer and asked me what I was working
on and I was like ah I'm teaching the
class tonight on some end game so I'm
actually using one of yours and he saw
this position and he said oh this move
is very important so I have it on good
authority that this is the very
important move so it's it's something
you know deeper than King to g1 it's got
a better idea than that
why would you play a rook to d7 what's
the idea yes so the problem with that is
like you know you can try to attack
these pawns with your rook but the thing
is you never really want to trade one of
these puns for this pawn right because
your pawns more valuable so there's no
way you can really achieve this you know
you any meaningful threats with your
rook while you're still having to
babysit this pawn so what white needs
instead is a way to kind of slow down
black you know say okay this move is
gonna cramp your forces there's no way
for you to kind of advance well as long
as I have this move yes so it's this
move g4 so Wesley so told me g4 very
important move and the reason is I mean
it's it's stopping black from ever doing
this in the near future it's stopping
black from especially getting this
active counter play so we can see if
something like qg1
maybe g4 for black would actually be
quite good when all of a sudden he's
making his own kinds of threats with
this pawn right all of a sudden you can
kind of see okay if my Europe gets you
know too distracted all of a sudden
there will be threats on g2 and then all
of a sudden black is queening so this
move g4 very important and it's a common
idea like this even in even in other
positions where you have this type of
pawn structure right one pawn stopping
two is always going to be beneficial so
we see g4 came to f6 trying to activate
the King of course this is giving up the
pawn but it's tough to find another move
for black right I mean what can even can
Kenny even try it besides just passing
with the rook when of course now your
idea of bringing the king over becomes
you know quite reasonable so we do see
King to have six giving up this be pawn
white takes it black activates this King
back to b7 of course we want to keep our
a upon King to f4 so now we see before
any black concerns counter play he's
having to deal with this cheap on of
course this is giving up f7 with check
white doesn't want to just yet I
gets his King more active first tix and
now c5 f5 and c6 and here
black resigned so what do you think
happened here why did black choose like
this position to resign
what's the winning plan for white yeah
so you're asking like King 2d for here
yeah the thing is since this is one pawn
stopping to white can simply just defend
this pawn forever black isn't gonna be
able to make any threats on the Kings
side until this pawn is gone so white
simply defends this pawn and then
continues with this plan here well yeah
the Rick is stuck stopping the pawn
white circuit stuck defending the pawn
but you know white can do more useful
things with his request well it's stuck
um so yeah like white would just defend
this pawn and then uh I don't see
anything for black other than coming
here you can try to pass but again uh
you know the king is coming and you know
maybe I'll play a c5 at some point as
well there's nothing to really nothing
to really be done I think you know the
King can't invade anywhere so you know
white wins this game but yeah g4 again
one pawn stopping - it's always a very
good thing to have in your games it's a
very important idea what do you mean
and saying how specific is the deeper
idea to like that point in time yeah you
know say black took a more passive
approach like this now here it doesn't
make as much sense to play G for cuz you
still have this have to pawn I guess so
let's try to construct some position
where it makes sense for this to happen
okay say black went like here and white
went like here and black went like King
g7 already I think it makes a lot of
sense to put this pawn here and so
what's the downside to putting the pawn
on g4 basically there is a downside
yeah the downsides that makes the pawn a
lot weaker right it removes the pawn
from the defense of the King but the
upside of is of course you know it's
stopping these pawns
so basically in this specific position
it becomes a good idea to play g4 when
the black rook can't easily just swing
around and take it so whether that be
because you know you have a pawn on the
seventh or because black has to babysit
this pawn either way it's it's probably
like a good idea now once the rook is
kind of immobilized in the game it might
have gone something like I don't even
know this looks terrible yeah I mean
it's it's already over so yeah at the
end of that game it's now 653 so if
you're playing in the Knights and want
to head back over you're welcome to do
that
thanks for coming out Richard hope you
learn something awesome and
yeah ya know cuz like in chess it's
always said that you know rook end games
are always like the most complicated no
grandmasters always mess them up which
is why we have all these principles to
fall back on and these principles are
actually quite reliable and grandmasters
are you know always using them you just
want to activate your pieces target weak
pawns and you know stuff like the
outside past pawn is more valuable
always also comes in handy so there's
one more game I want to look at one more
endgame and this one isn't actually a
rook endgame but it is quite an
interesting one this was actually a wild
game I won't uh-huh you know maybe you'd
be interesting to check out the middle
game as well but I do want to skip to
the endgame here that's the theme for
the night
so eventually we see yeah these rooks
come off and these rooks come off as
well so what's the material account for
stuff well let's go here
now what's the material again it's equal
right and we can see White has more pawn
islands but sometimes this isn't always
a bad thing right because white also has
more past pawns
so as far as pawn structure is concerned
White has more weaknesses but he also
has the ability to generate more threats
so this B pawn can come in quite handy
if it manages to get up the board so
we've looked at you know the pawn
structure White has more pawn weaknesses
but he also has more past pawns
what's the next thing to look at when
evaluating in games you know the kings
well yes so that's that's kind of a
misleading thing yeah so of course with
opposite colored bishops if you know the
game were to continue like this this
game might be drawn but with Queens on
the board it's it's a far different
story right so let's look at the Kings
first who has the safer King black by
far right
he has three pawns in front of his king
he has plenty of shelter and white is
you know open air open air and this is
always going to be important when there
are Queens on the board or like more
than one major piece especially so white
definitely has the weaker King he has
more passed pawns but also more targets
and then who has more active pieces yeah
White's Bishop is you know it's solidly
placed on c3 it's defending two of the
weak pawns White's King has white screen
is also centralized you know it's you
know defending the other two weaknesses
but blacks pieces aren't bad either
right you know this Queen has a lot of
options they can come into the second
rank the first rank it's attacking this
pawn can come to g4 if it needs this
Bishop has plenty of scope as well so
both players have active pieces weight
has a weak King White has more
weaknesses but also a passed pawn so
which side would you rather be here
ignore the scores would you rather play
with the white pieces or play with the
black pieces probably white
so yet we'll say I mean this is a rapid
time control you know I'm sure both
players rather be way interesting
interesting
so yeah of course black actually ended
up winning this game and I think black
does have a slight edge here and you
know this is something that I think is
undervalued a lot in these end games is
the safety of the King and that's really
what told the tale in this game was
something else that you know a lot of
people have been told about ponds
especially past ponds is their value
increases as they go up the board have
you heard that
so yeah this pond is still on b2 it's a
long way from being like a danger to
blacks position so yes he's going to
have to you know make sure this pond
doesn't get all the way up the board but
so why it's not going to be generating
many threats with it still and b2 the
last thing I want to mention about the
specifics of this end game is while this
pawn is passed you know you did mention
its opposite colored bishops and when
you mentioned it you said that makes it
more drought but you know specifics to
opposite color bishop end games the
reason it's Josh when there's only
bishops on the board is because it's
tough to push the pawns right this
bishop can always control b5 this Bishop
can never can control b5 right so that
makes the passed pawns difficult to push
and while you know that makes it drawn
when it's just the bishops on the board
that just adds another factor what the
Queen's still on the board right so
especially with Queens on the board one
reason it's not as jarash is because you
know white can't defend these squares
around his king with his bishop so that
makes light in his life a lot more
difficult so this game was kind of crazy
it took a long time for table to figure
it out but let's see how this game
continued we see King to f2 improving
his King defending this pawn h6 simply
giving his king left Queen to d4 Bishop
e6
Queen f4 it's kind of passing time
bishop d5 King III Queen b6 Queen D 426
King D - none of these moves are like
particularly you know groundbreaking
both players are just kind of
maneuvering their pieces towards better
squares Bishop back to e6 Queen d8 check
King age 7 check g6
Queen e3 so we see white our Black has
kind of created this sort of structure
around his King so you know he can't
really be checked from anywhere
Queen G - check can you 1 Bishop c4
Queen 2 f2 so white actually had a much
better option here which is kind of
keeping in line with the idea of piece
activity being more important than a lot
of things so try to find something you
know extremely interesting for right to
try here so you're talking like Queen d4
maybe so what's the obvious problem with
Queen d4 yeah okay but yeah you've got
the right idea
you know Black has created some
weaknesses in this camp by having to
push g6 so uh this movie 6 is actually
quite strong here for white yeah and you
know the White Queen might come here
it's defending this threat as well as
you know now threatening his own mate so
black would have to you know deal some
serious threats here maybe you would
play a check check and take but now what
has white forest yeah he's he's forced
to Queen trade when a the son games
going to be a lot lot harder to win for
black so this is an idea that a
dominguez unfortunately didn't spot or
didn't think was worth playing so in the
game and said we saw Queen - f2
Queeny for check king d2 and the players
continued shuffling around for a bit
Queen to f4 and now this move g5 gets
played what do you guys think about this
move
yeah why is it interesting mm-hmm one
thing is yeah the pawns are getting
closer down the board you're taking away
extra squares from white right
where has whites where of whites pieces
always you know been able to find a safe
home on the dark squares right so black
is trying to find a way to challenge
these dark squares which is exactly what
he needs to do if he wants to you know
make serious threats on whites King so
he's starting with this move g5 let me
see this move Queen to f2 and now let's
see if you can play like a genius
because topalov kind of showed why he's
you know he's he's so strong not just
with this specific move but you know
with his entire game plan that ended up
happening you know I always loved on
games where this idea gets gets a chance
to shine so how can white or how can
black ever try to challenge the dark
squares around this King around this
pawn around even this pawn how can he
ever achieve something like that
because it's it's first of all
physically impossible or legally
impossible with this Bishop this pawn
obviously isn't going anywhere and that
leaves you know just three other pieces
right so so yeah that's exactly what he
did in the game is he's slowly but
surely maneuvered his King up the board
to try to challenge these pawns the
other way to do it is by you know
pushing these pawns as well but you
really don't want to be trading off one
of these pawns for this pawn because
then again it's that much closer to a
draw it's that much closer to there's no
pawns left on the board I can't win the
game which is why you know couple
lobsters with king g6 we see this move
Bishop d4 Bishop c4 Queen e3 Queen c2
Queen very Bishop c3 Queen g2 we see
Queen f2 once again check and now King
h5 he inches another you know another
step closer up the board and the reason
he's allowed to do this is because now
let's see what would happen if white
were to check here
yeah the king can actually step up to g4
and then if white takes here
yeah queen 2e to check maybe and then I
can see one yeah and like White has to
come like all the way back to the Fendi
one but that leaves c2 so it's yeah
white would simply get made it so topple
of spots this which is why he he goes
for this King h5 move we see Queen to e3
now Queen G to Chuck King c1 Bishop e6
they should be one Bishop f5 Queen to d2
again you know it's White's just trying
to shuffle around trying to make sure
his King doesn't get exposed to too many
threats queenie for threatening Queen B
1 so we see Queen c3 giving us king of
square and now King g4 again he steps
closer right
b4 white finally decides now is the time
to try to push this pawn start creating
my own threats simply Queen d2 again
it's gonna be really hard for for white
to get through on these light squares
Queen d4 check came to h3 Queen c3 cb6
Bishop d2 and now finally King to g2 and
so black has actually found shelter
behind you know white spots instead of
his own and now all of a sudden there's
always this extra attacker on this g3
pawn right which makes things extremely
awkward for white to deal with in fact
he ends up just you know not being able
to deal with it right for the moment he
has but should be one to defense King to
f1 attacking the bishop forcing it back
to d2 and now King f2 with you know
controlling this square as well as this
square
all of a sudden black has gained control
of these dark squares right and this is
why this is why black is managing to win
this game we see Queen to a3 Queen c4
check King b2 Queen d4 check bishops III
Queen d1 finally a you know black has
allowed this pawn to get through to b5
but as you can see you know black is
allowed to make all these extra like you
know threats all these extra moves
because this pawn started off so far
away from queening now we see Queen e2
check King c1
Queen takes b5 actually so yeah it turns
out you know moving this pawn ends I'm
just losing it but so white didn't have
too many other choices so Bishop d4
check King g2 Queen e3 and now we see
Queen f1 Bishop c4 and eventually this
Queen have to remove and this is kind of
the the last straw
Black has managed to get rid of the
b-pawn and with this move he's trading
Queens as well as getting rid of the
Jeep on and the Sun game is simply lost
for lost for white game continued King D
to king g3 Bishop f8 takes takes and now
the quick walk down the board and white
resigned so yeah any questions about
this endgame because but opposite color
bishop been games with extra pieces on
the board are usually actually quite
interesting quite insane like this
absolutely yeah absolutely especially in
a format like this where you know
there's just a 10 second increment that
they were playing on for a long long
time but so yeah I mean that's that's
Topalov that's tupelo if he just does it
and wins the game easily just you know
it king f2 controlling the e1 square
controlling the g3 square you know what
else and you know that's that's why he's
the best so just a few ideas I want to
you know recap and hit home make sure
they make sense so when I'm evaluating a
position in the endgame what are kind of
the three things I'm looking at you know
the King's safety and the peace activity
and the pawn structure those are the
three main things obviously before all
those you count the material but that
kind of goes without saying and
oftentimes factors into the end of the
pawn count the pawn structure you know
some other ideas we touched on we're you
know outside passed pawns are always
going to be or are usually worth more
than pawns closer to the center closer
to the other King something else is this
idea of this G form of you know it shows
up in a different and a lot of different
endgame
it's not always G for a lot of the times
it's on the queenside with a move like
b4 or a move like a four but usually
it's always an important idea to keep in
mind the idea of stopping two pawns with
one pawn and yeah lastly the idea in
this in this first game was kind of just
you know active defense with the rooks
rather than just trying to push this
pawn black she tried to create more
threats on the Kings side yeah the time
control was 15 minutes plus the ten
second commit I believe but yeah all
these games happen today so you know
amazing chess like this is always going
on these amazing end games are always
going on so my advice especially if
you're trying to improve is to watch a
lot of these tournaments especially the
ones with commentary cuz you know like
gastrin Maurice and Jen always have
interesting things to say insightful
things to say about these end games and
if you have the chance to come out to
the club sometimes Wesley so tells you
what important ideas are so you might
want to hang around for those as well
yeah with that I'm gonna end it here
thank you guys for watching on youtube
thank you guys for being here in the
class testing all these wonderful
questions and I'll see you next time on
the road to 2000s
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]